هجمت نائبه صحيفه ارتس الاسرائيليه
التقارير عن صفقه بين رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الامن
القومي اتمار بن غفير ليوافق الاخير على
تاجيل خطه التعديلات القضائيه حزب القوه
اليهوديه بزعامه بن خفير اكد ان نتنياهو
سيؤجل خطته مقابل عرض تشكيل قوات حرس وطني
مدني تحت اشراف بن غفير فما هو هذا
التشكيل الجديد من المفترض ان يكون الحرس
الوطني جزءا من قوه حرس الحدود وذراعا
للشرطه الاسرائيليه بحسب الخطه ستحول
وحدات وتحول وحدات من حرس الحدود الى فيلق
للرد السريع في حاله الطوارئ ومواجهه
التهديدات الامنيه اين كان مصدرها كما
سيتم تجنيد الالاف من العناصر عناصر الحرس
الوطني لسيطره على الاضطرابات العنيفه
بحسب الخطه ما سيسمح للشرطه بالتركيز على
مهامها الروتينيه التقليديه ايضا الخطه
سيتالف حرس الحدود من قوى نظاميه واخرى
احتياطيه اضافه لقوه من المتطوعين من
المدنيين والشرطه المعارضون لفكره انشاء
القوى الجديده يخشون من ان تتحول لميليشيا
خاصه بوزير الامن القومي كما ينادي
المعارضون بعدم انشاء كيان اخر في دوله
لديها الكثير من الاجهزه الامنيه ايضا
لديها وزراء داخليه ودفاع ومن قومه في
التشكيلات الوزاريه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
اعتمر بن جبير يتولى منصب وزير الامن
القومي وهي تسميه مستحدثه لما كان يسمى
سابقا بوزير الشرطه صلاحيات لا علاقه لها
بالجيش او وزاره الدفاع الجديد ان بنجفير
اصبح مسؤولا عن الشرطه وحرس الحدود وجزء
من صلاحيات حرس الحدود الضفه الغربيه التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي من خلق
حساسيه مع وزير الدفاع صاحب السيطره
الشامله على الضفه وزير الماليه
للدفاع بهذا يكون مسؤولا عما يسمى
بالاداره المدنيه للجيش الاسرائيلي رغم
هذا التعيين لم يمارس سموترب صلاحياته لان
وزير الدفاع المستقيم منع تدخله في شؤون
الجيش
[موسيقى]